[Aplausos]
o anjo me disse que nós podemos ser deus
de nós mesmos e podemos dar um rumo na
nossa vida
vocês são o que vocês escolheram ser
vocês hoje aqui são o que você escolher
os e qual foi o exato momento que você
escolheu ser o que você é hoje
eu morei na rua com a minha mãe quando
era pequenininha e eu fui obrigado a ser
forte
sobreviver só com a ajuda da minha mãe
eu fui forte naquele momento quando
menina não tive opção
tive que ser forte e crescer assim um
belo dia eu fui convidada para ir à
alemanha eram passagens gratuitas
me chamaram para ir à alemanha fiquei
super feliz tirei o passaporte fiz o que
tinha que fazer
de repente eu estava na minha cozinha eu
ouvi assim cerimônia nenhuma sem
massagem
você não vai mais comigo pra alemanha
ariane estavam homens e eu disse e daí
você não vai eu falei assim como eu já
tirei o passaporte já vi quem vai cuidar
das crianças já fiz a mala e agora eu
não vou
não você não vai falar assim tá bom e
ele me disse assim você não vai brigar e
disse não você vai me trair não você vai
embora falei não vai lá vai para
alemanha
quando você voltar estará tudo melhor do
que o que você deixou aqui
daí para frente
naquele exato momento eu decidi ser
advogada
nesse exato momento e este exato momento
me trouxe até aqui neste momento quando
eu decidi ser advogada
eu não podia mais em sá e entrar à
esquerda ou entrar à direita
eu não podia engravidar a fugir da minha
missão
eu não podia ficar doente não perdeu o
foco e não podia brigar com o meu
companheiro que estava fazendo coisas
que me desagradavam pra não sair da
minha da minha reta
a partir do momento que eu decidi ser
advogada
os ventos só me trouxeram grandes
desafios e eu encaro os grandes desafios
porque a gente é o que a gente quer ser
a gente faz o que a gente quer fazer mas
aí vocês podem me perguntar mas é fácil
assim porque existem pessoas que ficou
dando voltas envolvem em torno do seu
próprio rabo porque existem pessoas que
nunca vencem porque existem pessoas que
passam a vida sem o amor verdadeiro que
passa uma vida sem um bom trabalho que
passa uma vida sem conseguir fazer uma
viagem que passa uma vida infeliz como
se tivesse recebido uma droga que passa
uma vida prolongada
existem pessoas que passam a vida
girando em torno do seu próprio rabo
porque tem medo de dizer eu quero
as pessoas dizem eu desejo eu gostaria
elas não dizem eu quero
as pessoas têm medo de encarar o tamanho
das escolhas que fizeram eu passei sete
anos estudando
casamentos velórios shoppings é enterros
eu não ia à aabb leiro manicure e no
final nem a depilação e hungria
graças a deus acabou
você pode dizer mas sete anos fazendo
uma coisa que você nem sabe se vai dar
certo
eu estava fazendo o que eu queria eu
estava fazendo o que eu escolhi esse
isso depois de sete anos não desse certo
eu ia mudar um ea dormir o sono dos
justos porque eu fiz o máximo eu dei o
meu máximo eu fiz o tudo o que eu
poderia fazer
e aí eu ia fazer outra coisa feliz da
vida a gente tem que ter coragem de
encarar as nossas escolhas
tem que ter coragem de assumir o tamanho
das nossas escolhas
eu acredito piamente que a partir do
momento que a gente tem um desejo e esse
desejo verdadeiro ele é materializado e
toda a nossa vida direcionada para este
desejo
então não adianta a gente ficar virando
à esquerda e à direita
nas ruas nas avenidas das nossas vidas
porque vai ficar a vida inteira como se
tivesse recebido uma droga
quando a gente faz o que a gente quer
pode ser um dois três sete anos
a gente faz e faz feliz mas para isso a
gente tem coragem tem que ter coragem de
dizer eu quero
e assim eu encerro dizendo pra vocês que
a realidade é uma mera ilusão ainda que
bem presidente como disse albert
einstein
muito obrigado